la conférence internationale sur la
libye s'est achevée elle avait pour
visée la sécurisation du processus
électoral dans le pays côté russe nous
avons suivi la conférence de presse du
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov qui faisait suite à la
réunion du midi avec jean yves le drian
et à cette conférence le chef de la
diplomatie russe a expliqué qu'un texte
très détaillé avait été adoptée afin
d'assurer le caractère inclusif du
processus électoral libyen emmanuel
macron a de son côté tenu une conférence
de presse à la suite du rendez vous
international au cours de laquelle il a
invité la russie et la turquie à retirer
sans délai leurs mercenaires selon
l'elysée des milliers de mercenaires
russes de la société wagner mais aussi
syrien tchadiens et soudanais sont
présents dans le pays on les écoute un
premier pas a été fait en effet avec
l'annoncé hier par le comité militaire
mixte des biens du retrait de 300
mercenaires
qui se prépare au moment même où nous
vous parlons à quitter la libye
ce n'est qu'un début mais c'est un début
essentiel qui crédibilise enfin un
processus dont nous parlons depuis trop
longtemps
ces mercenaires vont quitter donc dans
les prochaines semaines le territoire
libyen et je veux remercier
l'implication des pays africains voisins
en particulier du tchad ce processus se
fera dans le cadre d'un processus du ddr
qui sera supervisée par les nations
unies dans lequel nous sommes tous
profondément impliqués pour aider à la
supervisation est évidemment au
financement ce n'est qu'un début la
turquie la russie doivent aussi retirer
sans délai leurs mercenaires et leurs
forces militaires dont la présence mena
stabilité sécurité du pays et de toute
la région parallèlement la question des
mercenaires russes a été abordé par
sergueï lavrov mais au sujet du mali la
france s'inquiétait de l'intervention de
mercenaires de la société wagner dans le
pays or la coopération militaire avec
les russes au mali va se renforcer au
gré du départ des forces françaises a
expliqué le chef de la diplomatie russe
et voilà ce qu'il dit des sociétés de
sécurité privées autorités françaises
voulaient laisser ces territoires dans
le nord du mali où étaient leurs bases
et et en partant elle laisse le champ
libre aux groupes terroristes qui sont
actives sur place donc et ceci
s'accompagne de d'accusation à l'égard
de la russie selon lesquelles les
autorités maliennes se mettrait d'accord
avec des compagnies militaires privées
russes or cela ne repose sur rien nous
avons officiellement une coopération
technico-militaire entre la russie et le
mali nous aidons justement à la
formation des services de sécurité et de
l'armée malienne en ce qui concerne les
compagnies militaires privées
nous avons prévu nous avons prouvé par
les faits que c'est pas du tout un
phénomène russe et qu'au contraire ces
compagnies privées sont apparues dans
les pays occidentaux au contraire
toutefois ça gagne lavrov a indiqué que
la coopération avait pour visée la lutte
contre le terrorisme et que la réunion
avec jean yves le drian le ministre des
affaires étrangères avait conclu à la
mise en place d' effort concerté avec la
france à ce sujet